hey how's it going everyone Lord navel
juice here coming at you live with
another episode of postal 2 today is
Wednesday and Mary Goodwin tricks it's
more the many purposes of begging people
for money in the rain and the junkyard
Dan chassis hello there sir would you
like you today offering to help some
poor unspecified group of today's
society well then it appears that you
were all God that's all right
that's child right
Hitler was right I'm gonna have to take
your legs for this I'm gonna make a legs
don't look ma let's just go and do what
we need to do so in this episode we have
to find charity money get get a breast
pump and get the easy parts let's start
with the AC part show bit Martha Stewart
what are you doing here Martha big fan
Martha this is amazed I'm going in a
mace that's amazing yes I will kill
myself tonight don't worry about it
[ __ ] are the AC parts mate this must be
it I think that's it we found it already
risk high fibrous Wow
thanks what excuse me could you donate a
generous donation to this dubious
charity
don't point at me [ __ ] that's what you
get for not donating the best part about
the rain is that navel juice can flow as
much as you like and and no one will
complain about it
also if you cry in the rain no one will
tell either it camouflages the tears
well life hack therefore your breast hey
kitty here kitty here kitty here kitty
come here kitty kitty kitty kitty do you
like even if I shoot like this is that a
yes
don't talk back to me kitty good job
kitty that's how we treat racial people
I mean a racist people racism now racist
that's fried kitty alright we're at the
train yard
we got kitty kitty is happy shut the
[ __ ] up kitty or I'm gonna have to pee
on you again do you want that they don't
think so all right kitty taste my nipple
juice please
please rate my nipple juice from from a
scale to 1 to 10 what is my navel juice
tastes like that is it is an 8 it's an 8
isn't it yeah it's at least 7.5 notify
my kitty gonna hold a tag on a key
whoa whoa whoa whoa easy part what where
did you buy that hat we support the
charity was to me he supported the
charity coaches support the charity
would you like to please support the
charity oh my god there it is
yes ah all right so we have two parts we
just need that one and then we have to
get the breast pump so I I I would I
would say we go and get the breast pump
Bruce what do you say I can't I can't
hear you this is not it's not twitch and
even if it wants to twitch I'd have to
wait like 30 seconds to hear you and
holy [ __ ] that's just wait oh God that's
not gonna blow is it what the [ __ ] is
going on over there here have a gift
it's called death
what's that cool I'm pretty sure that
was cool is that a kidney is that a
kitty
Teddy Kaner right there kitty kitty
kitty kitty kitty kit your sky all right
let's get the AC part and get the [ __ ]
out
all right sure sure do what you gotta do
what you gotta be oh she's sleeping wake
up wake up I said wake up yeah that's
what they all say
gonna eat those legs gonna never love
them they taste like [ __ ] nuggets hey
don't judge have you ever tried a good
leg don't know a seaport isn't here I'll
stop you know one of these X's our take
is it a cow's head don't but this [ __ ]
was that no no okay
don't [ __ ]
oh my god oh my god
I can kick Rockets of course of course
have my camera being so bland get off
rockets dammit alright
no no
no no no no no no no
bah-bah-bah
oh [ __ ] [ __ ] one shot of that [ __ ]
right now I'm gonna have to take your
legs and I'm gonna make them into nice
little soup and you will enjoy it as
well now [ __ ] off
all right where were we oh yeah ac part
oh yeah it looks like I have a dead
cow's head now I'm gonna call him Jimmy
how you doing Jimmy huh
hates again Pearce how's it going take
Jimmy here enjoys company I ride I ride
Matthew McConaughey was a quick scoped
sniper that shot girls oh my god I think
she's having her menses kill her make
sure you purchased a buddy
god damn navel juice goddamn navels use
all this [ __ ] meal oh [ __ ] what the
[ __ ] is that what the [ __ ] are you doing
with that oh my god is that your legs I
will have all your legs sir
all your limbs all your limbs they're
mine they're mine they're mine
come here ah you [ __ ] you and
everything leg no leg give me your leg
give me your [ __ ] leg there we go
very nice don't run don't run don't run
give me your leg there we go give me
your leg there we go very nice no no
here we are there we go just leave your
legs need your legs I need your legs
there we go
give me your leg give me your leg all
right see if we all just work together
this would be so much easier all right
gasoline girl gasoline go and gasoline
go
that's a quad I just okay so now we're
gonna kill a sec wall did it appears
froze I'm sorry close your eyes because
I'm going to legally blind
Zack bored I'm gonna kill Zack board and
then I'm gonna grab his legs
and I'm gonna make some Zack would soup
the Nate's are overpowered shimmy booty
play I love you please don't sacrifice
damn it
I'm gonna have to sacrifice you to kill
stack board go Jimmy go Jimmy it's
working dudes
finish him I'm Swedish you idiot that
was best okay ever made right the soup
Zack board soup that for - Zack board
soup
Zack Floyd's soup Zacks well a note not
Jimmy alright so we did all it we did
all the things that we had to do let's
go back to blue all right but let's
finish this episode with some Christmas
singing breath give me your legs
I gave me your legs gave me what this
[ __ ] is going on there oh god no right
price
thank you for liking this episode it
helps me out a lot and support this
channel and it makes a bro and totally
not a homo not that there's anything
wrong with do whatever you want that's
it for now leave a comment about Zack
whatever sack you know and I'll see you
brothers the next one enjoy your leg
suit your job your rocket launcher man
okay listen sold the mother bought
gasoline girl gasoline what gasoline
girl gonna do what I gotta pee on her
face